after 7
which during the reading executed in 500
movements from inside to outside the
discovery of the truth
come the emotions that gave me
the action to which I did not take because
it is afternoon there was more filled
with dramatic events take the
often a lifetime it
was the events that occurred
in the book that I was saying it is true
that the characters they affected
were not real
as François said on May 5 all the
feelings that make us feel
joy or  importunate of a
real character but doubtfully occur
through an image of this
joy or this misfortune the ingenuity
the ingenuity of the first novelist
consisted in understanding that in
the apparatus of our emotions
the image being  the only essential element
the simplification which would be
to simply remove the
actual characters would be in
perfecting the ifs is nothing so
deeply that we sympathize with
him for a gr  ande part is perceived by
our senses
i.e. we remain opaque off it is
believed dead that our sensibility cannot
lift as it strikes
it it is only in a small part of the
total sum that we have of him that
we  we will be able to be much more moved by it it
is only in May
a part of the total notions that he has of
himself who will be able to be moved himself
the discovery of the novelist was to have
the idea of replacing these impen
trable parti
s  by an equal amount two immaterial parts,
that is to say that our soul
can assimilate
no matter when the actions the
emotions of these beings of bojan
appear to us as true since we
have made them ours since it is in all
cases occur that hold all the
dependence of a disc feverishly turning
the pages of the book the
rapidity of our breathing
the intensity of our gaze and
once the novelist has put us in this
state where as in all states
purely interior  any emotion and
couples and where his book is going to trouble us
and like a dream but a dream
clearer than what we have in
motion and in the memory of the rat
more so here is who tears
for an hour all the happiness and
all the  misfortunes possible in we would
put in the life of the years to
know some and of which the most
intense ones will never be settled because
the slowness with which they
occur us moreover the perception
thus our heart changes in the life and
it is the  worse pain but we don't we
gaps but we only know it
in nature in imagination that in
reality they change as in some
phenomena of my nature occur
slowly enough so that if we can
notice successively each of these
different states
on the other hand the  even feeling
changes
of self and already bet - inside my
body that this life of the character
came next a dream is projected
before me the landscape where to unfold
it has  ction and which exerted this my thought
a much greater influence than
the other than the one I had before my
eyes when I have the lips of the book this
is how for two summers in
the heat of the garden of understand I  I
had because of the book that I was saying then
the nostalgia mountainous and
fluvial buffer where I will see a lot of
syria and where at the bottom of the clear water
pieces of rotten wood it is under
tufts of pressure not far to go up
along the  low walls clusters of
purple flowers and redness and like the dream
of a woman kim would have liked was
always present my thought this was this
crazy dream imbued with the freshness of
running waters and whatever the woman
judge evoked the clusters of flowers
violets and reddish immediately rising
on each side of it like complementary colors
it was not only because an
image which we have always remained
marked embellishes and benefits from the reflection
of foreign colors which seemed
alent  bear of our one true that to his
landscapes of the books that I read
were not for me only landscapes
more vividly represented to my
imagination than what seemed repeated before
my eyes but which had been analogous
by the choice that we had  facts the author
by the time with which my thought
went ahead of his word like a
revelation
it seemed to me to be the impression that
hardly gave me chartered where
I was and above all our newspaper
produces its prestige from the correct
fantasy of the gardener  that takes and
my grandmother a genuine part of
nature itself worthy of study and
deepening if my parents had
allowed me when I was reading in book was
visited the area that described I
could have done below  invaluable in the
conquest of the truth because if we have the
feeling of being always surrounded by
saunas it is not like a
motionless prison earlier we are as if won
with it in a perpetual dash to
go beyond it to reach  outside
with a kind of discouragement
always hearing Thursday be this
identical sound which is not to be sure of the
outside but the repercussion of an
internal vibration we seek to find
in the things become by the
precious the reflection that our soul to
project on  l one is constantly disappointed that
they are devoid in the
jal nature which had in our thought in the
vicinity of this idea sometimes have
converted all the forces of this soul
into skill in splendor to act
on beings of we feel well that they
are located outside of us and that
we will wait for them we will never wait for
them also if I always imagined
around the woman that I loved the
places that I desired the most so so
just wanted that it was she who
enjoyed visiting who  opened the access
in my unknown
it was not by lazard of a simple
association to think no it is that my
dreams of travel and loves were
only moments that I have it is
parra difficult  slowly today as if I
practiced sections with other
criteria enter the
danger of organizing a mobile aperitif in
the same and inflexible flow
of all the forces of my life finally by
continuing to follow from inside to outside
the simultaneously juxtaposed states  in
my conscience and before arriving until
the real reason shrouded crisis I
find pleasures in our kind
that of being well if the sense of good
sea water not to be disturbed by
a visit
and when one o'clock strikes  at the bell tower of
saint-hilaire to see fall piece by
piece
what of the afternoon was already
consumed until I heard the
last knock which allowed me
to add up and after which the long silence
that  would follow without going to start
in the blue sky all the part which
put one can concede to read
until the end said not to dismiss Françoise and
which would comfort me from the fatigues taken
during the reading of the book
following its  tax and every hour it
felt like it was only moments
before the previous one
had that link the most recent relay was
drawing right next to each other in the
sky and I couldn't believe 60 minutes
stood in  this small arc the which
was between the two
golden marks is however even 7h premature
this the two shots more than the
last it had so a I had
not heard something that had not taken
place had not taken place  for me
the interest of the magic reading of a
deep sleep had given the change
but would have hallucinated and erased the
golden bell on the
azure surface of silence you
Sunday afternoon under the chestnut tree of the
Cambrai garden carefully emptied by months
media incidents from my
personal distance I will replace with a life
of adventurers of strange inspiration
within one of the watered with living water you
but still wauquiez this life when I
think of you and tell you is
indeed  for  the way little by little bypassed
and closed
alice that I progressed in my reading
and that the heat of the day fell a price
slowly changing successive stages and
crossed the foliage of your hours
silent fragrant sonorous and limpid
sometimes I was pulled from  my reading
in the middle of the afternoon by the
gardener's daughter who was running like
crazy sends her away without being in her way
in orange and cuts her finger
it's breaking a tooth and creating a book
there and that's it for Françoise and  me
we ran we didn't miss anything of the
show it was the days when for
garrison maneuvers the troop
crossed congress generally taking
the rue saint hildegarde while our
two mosquitoes
sat in a circle on chairs in
agri order watching the Sunday walkers
of progress  and made themselves visible from them the
daughter of the gardener by the font that to
leave between them of houses distant
from the avenue of the station had seen the
cases of the helmets and dome  tics had
hurriedly tucked our chairs when
the worst of these challenges the streets holy
guard
they filled it's full breadth
and galloping horses razed the houses
covered and sidewalks submerged cost of the
banks offering in bed too narrow
a torrent  unleashed